Sie haben das Aufnahmegeschrieb geführt.
Sind Sie damit ein Verstander?
Ja, natürlich.
Vielen Dank.
Ich heiße Marta Baumgart.
Marta mit H, oder?
Mit TH, genau.
Ja, mit TH, genau.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Baumgart?
Frau Baumgart, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 66 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 8. 2. 56.
58.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,56 m.
Und ich wiege 84 kg.
Okay, Frau Baumgart, was kann ich heute für Sie tun?
Ja, jetzt geht es mir schon wieder besser.
Aber heute Morgen hatte ich mit einmal solche starken Schmerzen.
Ich hatte eine schwere Wasserkiste in der Küche verschoben.
Von einer Stelle zu anderen.
Mit einmal habe ich solche Schmerzen bekommen.
Hier oben in der Brust.
Ganz starker Schmerz.
Ich habe mich in den linken Arm und die Schulter gestrahlt.
Hier hoch bis zum Unterkiefer habe ich wirklich Angst bekommen.
Als ich mich wieder hingesetzt habe und geschlauft habe in Ruhe,
ist es wieder besser geworden.
Aber das hat mir schon große Angst gemacht.
Ich muss auch so komisch husten.
Ich habe so einen ganz trockenen Husten.
Ich möchte kurz zusammenfassen,
ob ich die Brust schmerze habe.
Wo genau sind diese Schmerzen mit?
Oder auf der linken Seite?
Ich würde sagen in der Mitte.
Hinter dem Brustbein.
Ja, verstehe.
Und diese Schmerzen strahlen in den Kücher.
Und rinken Arm auch.
Das strahlt alles hier links.
Einmal hoch und einmal in den Arm rein.
Frau Baumgart, ich möchte kurz unser Geschiff unterbrechen.
Und sich stationär aufnehmen.
Und sofort ein EKG durchführen.
Und kurz Brut abnehmen.
Nicht immer, aber diese Beschwerden kann
die Schmerzen nicht mehr aufnehmen.
Ich möchte sie her sein.
Dann ist das gut, dass ich doch gekommen bin.
Dann gebe ich Ihnen ein paar Schmerzmittern.
Und Oxygen.
Dauerstoff auf natürlich.
Dann können wir dauern.
Ist das gut?
Ja, das machen wir jetzt weiter.
Ist Ihnen übel oder schwindelig?
Ein bisschen übel ist mir schon, aber nicht wirklich doll.
Okay.
Haben Sie erbrochen?
Nee, musste ich gar nicht.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Frau Baumgart auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10.
Wobei 1 leichte, 10 stärkste Schmerzen sind.
Die Schmerzen waren schon wirklich heftig.
Jetzt ist es ja alle wieder weg.
Man hat gesponnen.
Aber ich würde diese Schmerzen schon bei 7.
Wahrscheinlich 6, 7 anordnen.
Was eben das Schlimme ist, dass man so Angst bekommt.
Wie würden Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dumpf wie Messer?
Nee, ihr zieht so.
Ein bisschen zieht drückt vielleicht.
Drückt auch.
Haben Sie einen Husten?
Ja, ich guße so ein bisschen trockenen Husten habe ich.
Da wird es noch?
Nur war diese Husten beider schwer?
Ja, jetzt muss ich auch noch mal so ein bisschen nach Husten.
Ist Husten trocken oder mit auswurf?
Ja, da kommt nichts raus.
Es ist nur so ein Bellhusten.
Hatten Sie einen Schmerzen oder ist es zu mehr?
Ja, wahrscheinlich hatte ich das schon mal.
Aber da war das nicht so krass.
Ich bin mal mit dem Fahrrad gefahren.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es ein bisschen anstrengend ist.
Aber dass ich jetzt solche krassen Schmerzen habe, das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen etwas eingenommen?
Nein, nein, ich bin gleich hierher gekommen.
Das ist eine absolut gute Entscheidung.
Wie lange es dauert?
Ja, mir kam das natürlich lange vor.
Wahrscheinlich war das gar nicht so lange.
Aber es war jedenfalls so, dass es mir Angst gemacht hat.
Dass es nicht sofort wieder weggegangen ist.
Ich habe eine Stunde oder so.
Haben Sie einen Ausdoser bemerkt für diese Schmerzen?
Ich habe diese Wasserkiste geschleppt.
Ja, ja, vielleicht.
Die ist schon schwer, so eine volle Wasserkiste.
Ich glaube, das war irgendwie nicht so gut.
Und sind Ihre Schmerzen etwas abhängig?
Zum Beispiel, wenn Sie liegen, wenn Sie laufen, wenn Sie sitzen,
verändern Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, als ich mich dann hingesetzt habe und wie gesagt,
so ein bisschen zu Ruhe gekommen bin, sind die ja wieder besser geworden.
Jetzt, Ihre allgemeine Zustand habe ich, wie ich Ihnen möglich ein paar Frage.
Letzte 3 oder 6 Monate, haben Sie Fieber, Frau Baumgart?
Nein, Fieber habe ich natürlich nicht.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit abgenommen?
Nein, ich habe nicht abgenommen. Leider nicht.
Welcher ist schön?
In der letzten Zeit haben Sie, schwitzen Sie besonders in der Nacht nach Schweiß?
Nein, wegen Schwitzen wache ich nicht auf.
Ich wache nur auf, weil ich auf die Toilette muss.
Ja, vielleicht.
Wie viele Kisten schlafen Sie?
Für die vielen Kissen.
Ja, zwei habe ich schon.
Wenn Sie vielleicht liegen, kriegen Sie Probleme?
Wie Atmungproblem, oder?
Das ist einfach nicht angenehm, deswegen schlafe ich jetzt mit den zwei Kissen.
Schlafen Sie gut, außer auf die Kulom?
Nein, nicht wirklich gut.
Darf ich fragen, warum?
Vielleicht bin ich ein bisschen unruhig, aber schlafen tut ich wirklich nicht gut.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Frau Baumgart?
Der ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Ja, beim Wasserlassen nach muss ich relativ häufig mal raus.
Ja, ich habe auch mit dem Stuhlgang Probleme.
Ich habe häufiger mal Verstopfung.
Und dann muss ich so Movikulbeutel nehmen.
Jetzt Ihre Vorgeschichte, Frau Baumgart.
Haben Sie chronischer Krankungen von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, in meinem Alter hat man natürlich eine Menge zu bieten.
Ich habe seit zehn Jahren Diabetes.
Der Blutdruck ist auch ein bisschen hoch.
Genauso sind auch die Blutfettwerte.
Der Arzt sagt immer, ich muss Diät machen und Gewicht runter.
Aber das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Und dann hat man auch noch vor drei Jahren festgestellt,
dass ich auch so zu Gicht neige.
Und jetzt muss ich da auch mit den Essen aufpassen.
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Ich möchte jetzt mal die Schritte gehen.
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdruck?
10 Jahre jetzt schon.
Und die Blutfettwerte?
Das ist auch 10 Jahre.
Das hat man alles so zur gleichen Zeit.
Seit drei Jahren haben Sie auch Geht.
Wo haben Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, die Gebärmutter ist entfernt worden.
Ich hatte eine Senkung.
Da hatte ich Schwierigkeiten.
Das ist operiert worden.
Dann hatte ich vor langer Zeit mal einen Arbeitsunfall.
Da hatte ich einen komplizierten Handgelenkbruch.
Auf der linken Seite?
Auf der linken Seite.
Das ist operiert worden.
Dann habe ich auch noch auf der linken Seite
ein neues Kniegelenk bekommen.
Weil ich Arthose habe in den Kniegelängen.
Wo haben Sie schon mal die Situationen aufgenommen?
Auf dieser Operationen?
Aus anderen Gründen eigentlich nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Movicol eingenommen haben.
Und noch etwas?
Weil Medikamente nehmen.
Inzwischen brauche ich ja eine ganze Menge Tabletten.
Einmal soll ich aspirin 100 nehmen.
Dann nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Dann habe ich so etwas für den Magen.
Das heißt Pantohex haben.
Das ist eine andere Menge.
600.
Dann nehme ich Delix.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel.
Dann nehme ich noch mit Formin.
Für den Diabetes.
Oder gegen den Diabetes besser gesagt.
Dann habe ich noch Walzatan.
Also Druck.
Dann nehme ich eine morgens.
Dann nehme ich auch eine morgens.
Morgen und abends.
Das ist 500.
Und Walzatan.
Das ist Walzatan 160.
160.
Und wann nehmen Sie?
Das nehme ich auch morgens.
Braucht nicht mehr viel Frühstück bei den vielen Tabletten.
Ja, verstehe.
Sind Sie alles?
Das ist alles, ja.
Das ist alles.
Ich habe eine Jodh Allergie.
Ich habe eine Penicillin Allergie.
Wie ist das Allergie?
Ja, mit Haut, Rötung und Jucken.
Bei den Penicillinen habe ich zusätzlich auch noch so.
Im Gesicht.
So eine Rötung bekommen.
Ich habe eine Penicillin Allergie.
Und das juckte in den Augen und in den Schleim.
Das war gar nicht schön.
Vertragen Sie alle Essen gut?
Essen kann nicht alles.
Ja, ja, ja.
Jetzt Ihre Gewöhnheit.
Frau Baumgart, rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche seit 10 Jahren nicht mehr.
Aber vorher habe ich viele Jahre schon geraucht.
Aber seit 10 Jahren bin ich nicht drauf.
Wie lange seid ihr vorher geraucht?
Das waren schon 35 Jahre, die ich geraucht habe.
Ich habe nicht jeden Tag ein Päckchen geraucht.
Aber so 15 Zigaretten am Tag habe ich schon geraucht.
Das ist eine absolut gute Entscheidung.
Ich habe nicht jeden Tag ein Päckchen geraucht.
Aber so 15 Zigaretten am Tag habe ich schon geraucht.
Das ist eine absolut gute Entscheidung.
Trauer uns auf zu hören.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Mal ein Stück, wenn ich irgendwo eingeladen bin.
Mal ein Stück Sekt.
Aber wenig Alkohol.
Trinken Sie nur elegantlich Alkohol?
Darf ich fragen, was trinken Sie?
Mal trinke ich ein Glas Wein oder ein Glas Sekt.
Und im Sommer, wenn es so richtig heiß ist, dann trinke ich auch gerne mal ein Bier.
Da muss es aber schon sehr warm sein.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, haben Sie schon einmal mit Drogenkontakt.
Mit Drogen? Ich? Nein, nein, nein, da habe ich überhaupt gefehlt.
Bei meinen Kindern war ich mir dann nicht immer so sicher, aber ich habe dann nie etwas mitzutun gehabt.
Meine Eltern?
Ja, meine Mutter, mein Vater lebt noch, der ist hoch betagt und da ist demins krank und lebt im Altersheim.
Das ist schon eine mühselige Geschichte.
Und meine Mutter ist früh gestorben, die hatte Leberkrebs, die ist nur 60 Jahre alt geworden.
Ja, eine Schwester habe ich.
Die ist ein bisschen jünger als ich.
Ist sie gesund?
Nein, die ist gar nicht gerühnt. Die hatte tatsächlich vor einem Jahr einen Herzentakt.
Hat sich aber zum Glück gut erholt davon.
Oh Gott sei Dank.
Vor einem Jahr haben Sie gesagt,
Sie sind schon Rentnerin oder?
Ich bin jetzt Rentnerin, ja, ja.
Was waren Sie von mir?
Ich habe als Schneiderin gearbeitet.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verwitzelt, mein Mann ist verstorben, der ist beim Autorenfall ums Leben gekommen.
Ich bin so leicht verliebt.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben vier Kinder.
Sie sind aber jetzt schon alle groß.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ja.
Jetzt Frau Baumgart, ich bin mit meinen Fragen am Ende.
Falls Sie Fragen haben oder etwas hinzufügen möchten, ich bin für Sie da.
Sie haben ja so viel gefragt und ich habe Ihnen so viel erzählt.
Ich glaube, da fällt mir jetzt nichts mehr ein, was ich dann noch ergänken könnte.
Hauptsache wäre jetzt für mich, dass man mal gucken, woher das kommt.
Und dass mir das nicht wieder passiert.
Das ist so ein unguter Zustand.
Oder dass Sie mir sagen, was ich machen muss dagegen.
Mit sehrigen Angaben gehe ich wahrscheinlich auf einen Herzprobleme vor.
Aber das ist zu früh zu sagen, was Sie genau haben.
Ich muss versichere Sie körperliche und körperliche Untersuchungen.
Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen.
Dann werde ich EKG durchführen.
Das ist eine Grafik.
Ich glaube, Sie kennen die elektronischen Grafiken.
Dann eine Röntgen Torax durchführen.
Mit allen Ergebnissen komme ich zu Ihnen zurück.
Dann gebe ich Ihnen alle Ergebnisse.
Ja, das klingt doch gut.
Danke.
Gut hat noch irgendjemand von den Kollegen.
Ergänzung, Fragen, irgendwas.
Haben Sie Geschehe oder dabei?
Ah, nee, hat sie komischerweise nicht.
Stimmt, haben Sie aber nicht gefragt.
Haben Sie nie ein Problem, weil Sie Ramipril und Walzartan benutzen?
Oder warum benutzen Sie beide Medikamente?
Was nehme ich normal?
Ramipril nehme ich nicht.
Delix, Walzartan.
Delix, ACA HEMA.
Walzartan.
Eine Antipartensive.
Sartan-Gruppe.
Ah, ja, okay.
Vielleicht wegen der Buchshälte?
Wie bitte?
Walzartan vielleicht einmal wegen des Drucks
und wegen der höchsten Kolosterinwerte?
Ich denke nein, aber Walzartan benutzt
normalerweise Arterealhypertone.
Die habe ich ja auch.
Aber sie haben gesagt, ich benutze Delix und Walzartan.
Delix ist ACA HEMA.
Walzartan ist Angiotensin Receptor Blocker.
Normalerweise benutzt sie nicht beide Medikamente.
Manchmal benutzt sie im Niren-Problem.
Bin ich jetzt natürlich überfragt, kann ich nichts zu sagen?
Nur Fragen, tut mir leid.
Ich habe keine Info dazu.
Müssen Sie mit meinem Haus ausreden?
Ich dachte, dass Sie einen Niren-Problem haben.
Nee, es ist nicht aufgeführt.
Sie hat aber auch genug anderes Jahr.
Okay, okay.
Alles klar.
Sorry, kann ich nicht mit Informationen dienen?
Nein, keine Sorgen.
Ich habe die Infostatus gefragt.
Leider nicht.
Am Anfang sollte ich, aber es wurde nicht gefragt.
Ich vergesse das auch immer.
Wir sind schon zu Corona-Müden.
Wir haben das schon wieder vergessen.
Ich bin nicht so gut geimpft.
Natürlich bin ich 3-mal geimpft als Frau Baumgart.
Als Geld bin ich sogar 4-mal geimpft.
Die Patientin ist aber geimpft.
Seit wann haben Sie trockenen?
Den hatte ich schon lange, seit 4 Monaten.
Haben Sie aufstoßen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe den nicht aufstoßen.
Ist Ihnen aufgefahren eine Aufstoßage für die Trockenaußten?
Darf ich die Frage noch einmal hören?
Das ist ein bisschen allergisch, aber das habe ich seit 4 Monaten.
Kein Autoser bekannt.
Wann trete die Husten auf?
Morgen.
Ich glaube morgens muss ich Husten, wenn ich aufwache.
Und wenn ich mich anstränge, glaube ich auch.
Ja, ich glaube, ich werde auch aufwachen.
Können Sie ohne Pause auf den Treppe steigen?
Ja, so schnell bin ich ja nicht mehr.
Ich habe ja auch schon ein günstigiges Kniegelenk.
Da geht das schon mal nicht so schnell.
Ein bisschen langsam bin ich schon geworden in der Zwischenzeit.
Haben Sie Atemnot beim Schmerzen?
Ja, ich habe schon ein bisschen.
Ich habe schon ein bisschen.
Haben Sie Atemnot beim Laufen oder Hauptreppen?
Nein, ich merke nur, dass es mir ein bisschen schwer fällt.
Aber so richtig dolle Atemnot habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie...
Ich habe ein paar Geschenke.
Okay.
Können Sie schon?
Ja.
Gut.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarztin.
Ich möchte Ihnen unsere neue Patiente,
Frau Marta Baumgart über Frau Marta Baumgart berichten.
Frau Marta Baumgart ist eine 66-jährige Patientin,
die sich bei uns wegen Morgen plötzlich aufgetreten hat.
Diese Schmerzen würden in den Winkenarm und in den Unterkiefer aus Stralen
und die Patientin püpte hinzu, dass sie seit Piamonaten Husten habe.
Die Schmerzen in den Städten wurden auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10, 6 bis 7 abgegeben.
Die vegetative Anamnese, die uns auf die Insommi, die Nektüre und die Obstipation haben.
Die Patientin leide an eine M-Vibetesmeletus,
eine Artariell-Hypertoni und eine Hyperlipidemi.
So wie Artritis Urika.
Die Patientin sei wegen einer Linkshandgelenksfraktur operiert worden.
Sie wurden wegen der Neubau-Knie total endoprotest operiert.
Sie nehmen 100 mg morgens aus Pirin und haben 600 mg morgens Panthexol.
Sie nehmen 500 mg morgens abends mit 400 mg morgens.
Sie nehmen 600 mg morgens aus Pirin und haben die Panthexol.
Exem und Prüritus, Penicillin allergie oiser esich mit Exem und Prüritus.
Sie, sie seit seit zehn Jahren mit Traucherin vor her hab ich sie 530 Jahre
lang, fünfzehn Zigaretten am Tag geraucht.
Sie trinken nur elegantlich Alkohol und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Ihr Vater leide an einem Demenz, lebe in einem Altersheim.
Ihre Mutter ist sei wegen Leberkartsnoms verstorben.
Sie habe eine Schwester und die vor einem Jahr
Myokartinfarktus erlitten habe und Frau Marta Baumgart sei
Rentnerin ehemaliger Schneiderin.
Sie sei fervit für die Habefiakin und sie seien gesund.
Mit serigen Angaben gehe ich wahrscheinlich auf
Coronar-Herz-Sendrom hin, akut Coronar-Sendrom hin,
differenzial diagnostisch kommen
auf die Sektion und
Myokartinfarktus auch in Betracht.
Ich würde gerne diese Patientin Stationär aufnehmen
und Körperliche untersuchen,
Volute aufnehmen.
Wo achten Sie bei der Körperlichen Untersuchung?
Zuerst Herzoskultation und Brustlungenoskultation auch.
Zur Ausschließung Art Section würde ich gerne
beidseitig Tensionen messen.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Erwägung gezogen,
dass Sie vielleicht auch irgendwie einen Lungenproblem haben,
kommt er?
Höchstwahrscheinlich nicht.
Okay, gut.
Und was machen Sie labortechnisch?
Labortechnisch, Kardiak, Enzymen wie Troponim
und ich würde auch bestimmen.
Und zkm, trp und Troponim.
Gut, was machen Sie weiter, technische Untersuchung,
operative Untersuchung?
Ja, Eko-Kardiografie, EKG und Angiografie,
Coronar-Angiografie.
Genau, genau.
Dass die das machen, die Kardiologen.
Ja, genau.
Sehr gut.
Okay, gut.
Wenn Sie jetzt, wenn sich das bestätigt,
dass die tatsächlich ein Problem haben,
dann ist es, dass die das nicht,
dass die das nicht,
dass sie das bestätigt,
dass sie tatsächlich ein Problem hat
mit den Herzkranzgefäßen.
Wenn sich das bestätigt, wenn sie den Verschluss hat.
Was machen wir dann?
Ich glaube, das hängt vom,
wie der Verschluss ist ab.
Wenn Verschluss mehr als 90 Prozent
im Kantieren stand.
Aber ich bin nicht Kardiolog,
deswegen habe ich nicht so ausführliche Informationen.
Aber das ist ja nötig.
Okay, gut.
Dann werden wir die Fachleute von der Kardiologie noch fahren.
Gut, alles klar.
Vielen Dank.
Ich möchte jemand von den Kollegen noch etwas sagen dazu.
Aber wenn wir Kardiologie,
ja, ich glaube schon.
Bestimmt haben wir Kardiologen.
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Ich glaube schon.
Bestimmt haben wir Kardiologen.
Aber eins ist von denen krank.
Ja.
Aber auch eine Sache,
eine Sache ist mir aufgefallen.
Das ist auch so ein alter Hut,
das sage ich immer wieder.
Vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig,
bis auf Nygdorie, Verstopfung und Insumnie.
Dann finde ich, ist das nicht mehr unauffällig.
Das muss man sich mal überlegen.
Wenn ein Symptom da ist,
dann ist es sonst unauffällig.
Aber ich finde bei drei Sachen kann man schon sagen,
das ist nicht ganz unauffällig.
Mit diesem alt,
vielleicht mit diesem alt, ob das fast schon nicht klingt.
Ja.
Es gibt ja so eine schöne Kleidung.
Es gibt ja so eine schöne klassische Bezeichnung für diese Schmerzen.
Das wäre sehr schön,
wenn Sie den Fachbegriff bei der Kollegin dann auch benennen würden.
Wie heißen diese Schmerzen?
Die Lokalisation.
Nein, die Lokalisation.
Retro-Sternale.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ja, muss kommen.
Das muss kommen, der muss kommen.
Ja, natürlich.
Der muss kommen, der muss kommen.
Dann.
Bim, bim, bim, bim, bim.
Okay.
Unterschlagen, unterschlagen, haben Sie die Gebärmutter-Operation?
Oh nein.
Der Kollegin gegenüber, die haben Sie nicht erwähnt,
dass sie vor neun Jahren auch noch die Gebärmutter entfernt bekommen hat?
Aufnahmegesprächs gab einen Nachricht. Deswegen habe ich das. Ja, verpasst sein.
Ich muss achten, aber normalerweise ja. Da war noch was. Und tatsächlich hatte... Ach so, hier war noch
tatsächlich als Differenzialdiagnose war hier auch noch erwähnt.
Tatsächlich im Pneu- oder Nelungembo. Die finde ich aber eigentlich auch nicht so richtig typisch,
denn eigentlich diese retroschinalen und ausstrahlenden Schmerzen, das ist so ein Klassiker eigentlich für
diese Herzgeschichten. Wobei der Fall ist beschrieben als Angenapektorist tatsächlich.
Also die hat keinen Infarkt, sondern hat eben nur eine Angenapektorist.
Gut, aber sprachlich glaube ich, ist es kein Problem überhaupt nicht. Sie waren sehr nett und sehr
zugewandt zu der Patientin. Das ist mir aufgefallen, dass sie immer wieder sie auch beim Namen genannt
haben und auch immer so die Schritte erklärt haben, wo sie gucken müssen. Weiß ich nicht
wie das in der Prüfungssituation ist. Sie haben ja sehr richtig das Ding sofort unterbrochen,
als die ihre Schmerzen geschildert hat. Haben sie gesagt, wir machen jetzt erst mal EKG und ich
nehme Ihnen Blut ab. Und das ist natürlich bescheuert, wenn man dann hinterher sagt,
da ich dem Ihnen jetzt noch Blut habe und machen EKG, haben sie ja eigentlich schon gemacht. Aber
durch diese künstliche Situation vergisst man das halt wieder. Also ich weiß nicht wie das in
der Prüfung ist. Unterbrechen Sie dann tatsächlich und, was, was ich die Prüfer sagen, ihnen dann
die Patientin hat ein unauffälliges EKG und hat einen Blutdruck von so und so viel zu so und
so viel und die Sauerstoffsättigung ist okay oder müssen sie praktisch mit der mit der Fantasie
selber weitermachen. Ich weiß es nicht. Ja, in der München mit Fantasie, wir machen selber. Ah ja,
okay. Dann sind irgendwelche Werte, die zu der Patientin passen und machen dann entsprechend
weiter. Aber natürlich müssen sie dann auch hinterher sagen, ich habe ja schon einen EKG
gemacht. Das war ja zum Glück nicht so ganz unauf, nicht so ganz auffällig oder da haben wir
keine Besonderheiten festgestellt und ihre Sauerstoffsättigung war ja auch schon wieder ganz
gut. Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Das muss man dann natürlich auch kommunizieren. Aber
das ist jetzt irgendwie der Künstlichkeit der Situation geschuldet, dass sie da nicht
mehr dran gedacht haben. Aber es war natürlich super, dass sie sofort reagiert haben und
gesagt haben, halt, stopp, wir reden jetzt nicht weiter. Sie kommen jetzt erst mal an den Monitor
und danach gucken wir weiter. Okay. Und entsprechend müssen sie das natürlich auch dann ihrer
Kollegin oder dem Kollegen sagen, ich habe bei der Patientin das und das schon bereits gemacht,
um auch noch mal sicher zu gehen oder so. Okay. Gut. Also ich denke mal, das ist,
das ist gut. Das ist richtig gut und sie müssen vor der nächsten Woche keine Angst haben.
Ich hoffe, vielen Dank. Vielen lieben Dank. Danke schön. Ich gebe Ihnen sofort Bescheid.
Ja, das machen Sie auf alle Fälle bitte. Ja, natürlich.
Haben Sie mich mal gefragt, ob Sie mir die Berichte schicken können?
Nein. Jemand hat mich mal gefragt und ich habe aber nie einen Bericht bekommen.
Jemand hat mich gefragt, ob ich die schriftliche Version korrigieren kann. Dann habe ich geschrieben,
ja, geantwortet, ja, schicken Sie mir, schicken Sie mir eine Word-Datei. Ich habe aber nie eine
bekommen. Muss man entkucken, wer das war.
Irgendjemand aus der Gruppe. Genau. Luran Afchi. Haben wir die hier?
Nein. Sie hat bei uns gesagt, vielleicht können wir Sie unsere Dokumenten, unsere
Berichte korrigieren. Nur einmal habe ich im Chat gesehen.
Nur da. Ja, nur da. Das biete ich immer an. Wer auch immer mir seine Berichte schicken will,
der kann das machen. Ja, ich muss die nur als als Word-Datei bekommen, damit ich die,
damit ich die bearbeiten kann. Dann kann ich Ihnen die zurückschicken. Dann können Sie
die Korrekturen sehen. Ja, also das gilt immer für alle. Ja, und das geht immer am besten
über den Host, also jetzt über Dr. Gündiz, der kann meine, meine E-Mail-Ansprift rausgeben.
Da habe ich überhaupt nichts gegen und so jeder, jeder darf mir schicken. Ja, und
dann so schnell wie es geht, mache ich es fertig und schickst zurück. Ja, wenn das irgendwie
so Unsicherheiten gibt in den Formulierungen, mache ich immer gerne. Ja. Danke Ihnen, danke.
Sie sind sehr nett, danke schön. Gerne, ja, das merken Sie vielleicht auch. Mir macht
das ja Spaß. Ja, ich bin Rentner, ich habe Zeit und es macht mir ausgesprochen
auch ein Spaß und ich finde das sehr nett immer diese, diese Abende hier und ja.
Und ich finde es besonders nett, wenn jemand die Prüfung gesteht. Dann freue ich mich wirklich tierisch.
Wir auch. Insofern also halten wir mal die Daumen. Wann ist Ihre Prüfung?
29. Ist noch noch ein bisschen hin.
Ende der Woche dann erst. Ja. Gut. Wir sehen uns wieder am Donnerstag. Richtig? Richtig. Ja, alles klar.
Gut, dann wünsche ich Ihnen jetzt einen schönen Laun Sommerabend. Denken Sie daran,
heute ist der längste Tag und die kürzeste Nacht. So hell wird es so schnell nicht wieder.
Das ist wunderbar. Also machen Sie das Beste draus allen einen schönen Abend und tschüss.
Wir wünschen Ihnen einen Abend. Tschüss. Danke schön.